-Our next guest
is a Grammy Award
winning musician and songwriter
and frontman
of the band Wilco.
His book,
"World Within a Song --
Music That Changed My Life
and Life That Changed My Music"
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend Jeff Tweedy,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thanks for having me.
-It's lovely.
Thank you for doing
the jingle to our podcast.
-Oh. You're welcome.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like you
maybe forgot you did it.
-I did.
-Yeah?
Alright, well,
thanks for your honesty.
-Is it good?
-It's great.
-Yeah.
-Are you --
You're obviously not getting
as much feedback on it as I am.
-Oh. No. I like haven't. Yeah.
No, somebody told me.
No. Nobody told me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I love this book because --
And you've written others.
But this is a very unique take.
This is the songs,
individual songs where you write
just a few pages about
how important they are to you,
but you did not open it
with a very sort of hard
sell to the reader
as far as how special
an experience this would be.
Can I read you
the very first paragraph?
-Sure.
-Jeff Tweedy out of the gate.
This is very absent
of braggadocio.
"I'm going to level with you
right off the bat.
I don't know what I'm doing,
and I probably don't have any
business writing another book,
much less one is conceptually
conceived and philosophical,
as this one aims to be."
[ Laughter ]
So now, why do you want to have
people read that right away?
[ Laughter ]
-It's -- It's honest for one.
-Yeah, it is.
-But you know,
I actually read a review.
The only review
I've read of this book
said that they wish
I wouldn't be so humble.
-Oh.
-And I sent it
to my family.
And I said, "See,
I've always told you
that my humbleness
was my biggest weakness."
[ Laughter ]
-One of the things
you actually show
some humility about
is there are songs you loved
the first time you heard them,
and I think we all have
that relationship with songs,
but you also write
sort of a mea culpa
about a few songs
that you didn't like originally,
and then you came to appreciate
how great a song it was.
"Dancing Queen" by -- by ABBA.
-Right.
Undeniable.
-Undeniable.
But you denied for a long time.
-But I did deny.
But I denied it. Yeah.
-So how did it dawn on you
that you were wrong?
-Um.
I mean, a lot of things
started falling away
once I got out of
the early adolescent
and adolescent period.
And you start to realize that
there's a lot of great music,
and it doesn't all have to fit
into your identity
and character.
But, yeah, I was just standing
in the grocery store one day,
and it was playing on
the speaker right above me,
and I was just like, what is
this message from heaven?
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's so glorious.
It's so beautiful.
Yeah. And I'm really happy
when things like that, like,
reveal themselves
as their true nature.
And you don't have
the whatever context
you originally heard it in
with people like threatening
to beat you up
if you listen to it or,
you know, the different things
that we put in as barriers
and they all fall away and you
can just listen to something,
it's really good for you.
-I think it's also nice
when you point out in the book,
if there's a song that all
of a sudden now you like,
when you hear your world
just gets better,
having songs you don't like
is not a positive influence
on your life.
It's way better to find love
in things.
-Yeah. I mean, isn't that --
I mean, isn't that the goal?
-That's the goal.
-Learn to love more, everybody.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
-"Dancing Queen"
is a real...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Dancing Queen"...
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm running for office.
-Yeah, yeah, so take
that weird pro-love stance.
-Yeah.
-Let's see how it goes.
I think it's going to come back
to bite you.
It's like --
Yeah. Just floated it
out there like a test balloon.
-Yeah. See how it polls.
-Yeah.
-You talk about coming
to New York
when you were young
for the first time
and seeing a street musicians
and trying to bring back
their vibe,
maybe a little bit
of their fashion
when you went back
to to your Illinois,
your small Illinois town?
-Well,
I was mostly impressed by --
Well, first of all,
all of the musicians
I would see on the street
were a million times better
than -- than I am now.
-Right?
-I was really young and just
learning how to play the guitar,
and I was like,
wow, I really suck
and everybody's really great.
What are they doing
in Carnegie Hall?
You know? But it wasn't
so much their fashion.
It was just that they had
liberated themselves to be,
you know, artists
and play music for people
and felt like confident,
and I wanted some of that.
And so my mom
bought me a beret.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-And now, were you
the first kid at your school
in Illinois
to have a beret?
-Not. Not that anybody
in my school knows.
-Well, did you not
wear it to school?
-No, no, I made it home
with the beret.
-Okay.
-And I got out of my mom's car
with the beret on.
-To go to school.
-Yeah.
Yeah. And quickly...
[ Laughter ]
-Did it just dawn on you
that it wasn't going to work?
-I locked eyes with somebody
and realized the colossal
mistake I was making.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That I was never going
to be able to pull this off.
-And even now,
you don't beret it.
-No, I mean, I'm wearing a --
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-No, I think that there's Bel--
-Nobody thinks
you're not pulling this off.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah.
-Anybody can pull this off.
No, there's Belleville-Jeff,
and there's beret-Jeff.
And -- And the Belleville's
where I grew up.
And they're in a constant,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
Even to this day on stage
right now, at this very moment.
-Yeah.
-One of them is like,
"Who do you think you are?"
-Wow.
-So you're telling me
that Beret-Jeff is inside you,
right now, wondering when
he's going to get his time.
-Yeah, yeah.
Once you start, like,
talking about
how great the book is.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Here's the first
paragraph
in beret-Jeff's
version is like,
"You're about to have
your mind [bleep] blown."
-Exactly, exactly.
Yeah.
This -- This book should
revolutionize literature.
[ Laughter ]
-Now you talk about
and Mavis Staples, for example,
is someone you got to talk to
about how much one of her songs
meant to you.
I would imagine you have people
who come up to you all the time
to tell you a story about
one of your songs meant to them.
-Yeah, like the theme song
for your podcast?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And let me just say
I got everything I needed
from you out of that.
-Yeah.
-That was the dream.
-That's an example
of the only one
that no one has come up to me
and talked to me about.
-Alright.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, it's just...
-Is it a weird
message to receive?
-Oh, it's such a --
Yeah, it's a really --
it's a -- it's such a gift to,
to make something and,
and then come to understand
that it really did find somebody
and mean something to somebody.
And I'm going to cry
now talking about it. No.
But it's really it's
a seriously beautiful thing
to get to be a part of.
But you also can't look at it
directly very long
because it's not really
what got you to where you are.
It's not. I didn't really think
that that would happen
when I started writing songs,
and I can't think about it
when I'm writing songs now,
because that's just too much
weight to put on it, but.
-Yeah,
but it still must be nice.
I mean, again, right? You can't
think about it at the time,
but it must be just such
a wonderful sort of annuity
to your work that someday
somebody might come up to you
on any given song
and just be like,
hey, this meant this to me.
-Oh, it's the best.
I mean, it's -- I always say,
that's what it's for.
I mean, it is kind of like
the highest aspiration
is that you could,
you know,
keep somebody company in a,
in a, in a moment
where they need some,
some consolation, you know.
And then music does that
for all of us, I think.
-Well, it's a wonderful book.
The last Wilco album
came out September, also great.
-Thank you so much.
-And it is just
lovely to see you.
I'm going to see you later
on tonight as well.
-That's right.
-Double date.
Jeff Tweedy, everybody.
"World Within a Song"
is available now.
We'll be right back
with Ms. Pat.